Mes recherches consistent à trouver des moyens d'écrire des chroniques,
de partager, de relater des histoires à propos de personnes, des gens de tous les jours.
Des histoires qui cherchent à vous transformer, qui ont quelque chose d'universel,
mais qui ne sont jamais sentimentales,
qui ne détournent jamais le regard des choses les plus sombres en nous.
Parce que je pense sincèrement que nous ne sommes jamais aussi beau
que lorsque nous sommes le plus laid.
Parce que c'est à cet instant précis que nous découvrons ce dont nous sommes fait.
Comme Chris l'a dit, j'ai grandi au Nigeria
dans les années 1980 avec toute une génération
d'étudiants qui se rebellaient contre une dictature militaire qui est enfin terminée.
Alors il n'y avait pas que moi, nous étions toute une génération.
Je me suis rendu compte par expérience que
le monde n'est jamais sauvé par de grands gestes messianiques
mais par une accumulation d'actes de compassion gentils, doux, presque invisibles,
des gestes de compassion de tous les jours.
En Afrique du Sud, ils ont une expression, "ubuntu".
Ubuntu provient d'une philosophie selon laquelle
la seule manière pour moi d'être humain est
qu'un autre m'offre le reflet de mon humanité.
Mais si vous êtes comme moi, mon humanité est plutôt une sorte de fenêtre.
Je ne la vois pas vraiment, je n'y fais pas tellement attention
jusqu'à ce qu'il y ait, vous voyez, une sorte d'insecte mort dessus.
Puis soudainement je la vois, et la plupart du temps ce n'est pas de bon augure.
Cela arrive souvent lorsque je m'emporte contre quelqu'un
qui essaye de boire son café et d'envoyer des mails
et d'écrire des mémos tout en conduisant.
Ce que ubuntu veut dire
est qu'il nous est impossible d'être humain sans les autres.
C'est à la fois très simple et très compliqué.
Alors j'ai pensé que je pourrais commencer avec des histoires.
Je devrais vous raconter des histoires à propos de personnes remarquables,
alors j'ai pensé que je commencerais avec celle de ma mère.
(Rire)
Et elle aussi était noire.
Ma mère était anglaise.
Mes parents se sont connus à Oxford dans les années 1950,
ma mère est partie au Nigeria et a vécu là-bas.
Elle faisait 1m56, était très fougueuse et très anglaise.
Elle est ce type d'anglaise... enfin était, elle vient de décéder.
Elle est venue en Californie, à Los Angeles me rendre visite
et nous sommes allés à Malibu, cet endroit l'a beaucoup déçue.
(Rire)
Puis nous sommes allés dans un restaurant de poisson,
Chad le surfer était notre serveur,
lorsqu'il est venu à notre table ma mère lui a demandé :
"Proposez-vous des spécialités, jeune homme ?"
Et Chad a répondu : "Ouai, genre ... ça, du saumon,
qui est genre roulé dans ce truc, genre une de croûte de wasabi.
C'est une vraie tuerie."
Et ma mère s'est tournée vers moi et m'a dit :
"Mais quelle langue parle t-il ?"
(Rire)
J'ai répondu "Anglais maman".
Et elle a secoué la tête et dit :
"Oh ces américains ! Nous leur avons donné une langue.
Pourquoi ne l'utilisent ils pas ?"
(Rire)
Alors cette femme, une anglicane qui s'est convertie
au catholicisme quand elle a épousé mon père
-- il n'y a pas plus religieux qu'un converti catholique --
a décidé d'enseigner dans des régions rurales au Nigeria
en particulier aux femmes Igbo
la méthode d'ovulation Billings
le seul moyen de contraception autorisé par l'Eglise Catholique.
Mais son Igbo n'était pas très bon.
Alors elle m'emmenait avec elle pour traduire.
J'avais sept ans.
(Rire)
Alors, là il y a ces femmes
qui ne parlent jamais de leurs règles avec leurs maris,
et sur ce je leur dit : "Tous les combien avez-vous vos règles ?"
(Rire)
Et avez-vous des pertes ?
Et, votre vulve est-elle gonflée ?
(Rire)
Ma mère ne s'est jamais considérée comme une féministe,
cependant elle avait l'habitude de dire :
"Tout ce qu'un homme fait, je peux le réparer"
(Applaudissements)
Et quand mon père se plaignait de la situation,
du fait qu'elle emmenait un garçon de sept ans
pour enseigner ce moyen de contraception, vous savez,
il disait : "Oh mais tu vas le faire devenir une femme
si tu lui apprends comment en être une."
Ma mère rétorquait "Quelqu'un doit le faire".
(Rires)
Cette femme -- pendant la guerre du Biafra,
nous étions là quand la guerre a éclaté.
Cette femme c'était ma mère avec ses cinq jeunes enfants.
Il lui a fallut un an, errant de camp de réfugiés en camp de réfugiés,
pour atteindre une piste d'atterrissage par laquelle nous quitterions le pays.
Dans chaque camp de réfugiés, elle devait faire face aux soldats
qui voulaient emmener mon frère ainé Mark, qui avait neuf ans,
pour faire de lui un enfant-soldat.
Imaginez cette petite femme
se dresser face à des hommes armés voulant nous tuer.
Durant cette année,
ma mère n'a jamais pleuré une seule fois.
Mais quand nous étions en transit à l'aéroport de Lisbonne
prêt à s'envoler pour l'Angleterre,
cette femme a vu ma mère porter cette robe
qui avait été lavée tellement de fois qu'elle était pratiquement transparente,
avec cinq enfants à l'air affamé,
elle s'est approchée et lui a demandé ce qui nous était arrivé.
Et elle lui expliqua.
Et alors cette femme a vidé sa valisé
et a donné tous ses vêtements à ma mère, et à nous
les jouets de ses enfants qui n'avaient pas l'air d'apprécier, mais...
(Rire)
Ce fut l'unique fois où elle pleura.
Et je me souviens, des années plus tard, j'écrivais à propos de ma mère,
et je lui ai demandé : "Pourquoi as-tu pleuré à ce moment là ?"
Et elle me répondit : "Tu sais, on peut se blinder
contre toutes les menaces, toutes les horreurs.
Mais le plus simple acte de gentillesse d'un total inconnu
va détruire tes remparts"
Après la fin de la guerre, les vieilles femmes du village de mon père
ont retenu tous les noms de tous les morts,
et elles se sont mises à chanter des hymnes funèbres à partir de ces noms.
Des hymnes mélancoliques qui vous touchent profondément.
Et elles les chantaient seulement lorsqu'elles plantaient du riz,
comme si elles semaient les coeurs des morts
dans le riz.
Mais quand venait le moment de la récolte,
elles chantaient ces chants joyeux,
fait de tous les noms des enfants
nés cette année là.
Et quand revenait le moment de planter, elles chantaient les hymnes funèbres
en enlevant un certain nombre de noms de disparus
en fonction du nombre d'enfants nés.
Et de cette manière, ces femmes ont accompli beaucoup de transformations,
de belles transformations.
Saviez vous qu'avant le génocide au Rwanda
le mot pour viol et celui pour mariage
étaient le même ?
Mais aujourd'hui les femmes reconstruisent le Rwanda.
Saviez vous aussi qu'après l'apartheid,
lorsque le nouveau gouvernement s'est installé aux chambres du parlement
il n'y avait pas de toilettes pour femmes dans le bâtiment ?
Ce qui semble suggérer que l'apartheid
n'était qu'une histoire d'homme.
Tout cela pour dire que malgré l'horreur, malgré la mort,
les femmes n'ont jamais vraiment leur mot à dire.
Leur humanité ne nous préoccupe pas tellement.
Durant mon enfance au Nigeria...
et je ne devrais pas dire Nigeria car c'est bien trop général,
mais à Urhobo, la partie Igbo du pays d'où je viens,
il y avait encore des rites de passages pour les jeunes hommes.
On apprenait aux hommes à être des hommes c'est-à-dire à ne pas être des femmes,
c'est essentiellement en quoi cela consistait.
Et beaucoup de ces rituels avaient attrait au meurtre, au meurtre de petits animaux,
alors vers mes treize ans...
et je veux dire... cela se comprend, c'était une communauté agraire,
quelqu'un devait bien tuer les animaux,
il n'y avait pas de supermarché où aller acheter un steak de kangourou...
alors vers mes treize ans, ce fut mon tour de tuer une chèvre.
Et j'étais cet enfant bizarre et sensible qui ne pouvait pas vraiment le faire,
mais qui le devait.
Et j'étais censé le faire seul.
Mais un de mes amis, qui s'appelait Emmanuel,
il était vraiment plus âgé que moi,
il avait été un enfant-soldat pendant la guerre du Biafra,
a décidé de venir avec moi.
Je me suis senti un peu mieux,
parce qu'il avait vu beaucoup de choses.
Quand j'étais enfant, il me racontait des histoires,
sur comment il poignardait les gens à coups de baïonnette
et leurs intestins s'échappaient mais ils continuaient de courir.
Alors ce gars est venu avec moi,
et je ne sais pas si vous avez déjà entendu une chèvre, ou même vu une,
leurs cris ressemblent à ceux des êtres humains,
c'est pourquoi nous appelons les tragédies "un chant de chèvre".
Mon ami Brad Kessler dit que nous sommes devenu humains
quand nous avons commencé à garder des chèvres.
Bref, une chèvre vous regarde tel un enfant.
Alors quand j'ai essayé de tuer cette chèvre je n'ai pas pu.
Emmanuel s'est baissé, a mis sa main sur le museau de la chèvre,
lui a couvert les yeux, ainsi je n'avais pas à soutenir son regard,
et j'ai tué la chèvre.
Cela n'avait pas l'air important pour un gars qui avait vu bien pire
et pour qui l'abattage d'une chèvre devait être
un geste de la vie de tous les jours,
cependant il a essayé de me protéger.
J'étais un froussard.
J'ai pleuré un long moment.
Et ensuite, il n'a pas dit un mot,
il s'est juste assis et m'a regardé pleurer pendant une heure.
Puis il m'a dit :
"Ce sera toujours aussi difficile mais si tu pleures comme ça à chaque fois,
tu auras le coeur brisé à en mourir.
Retiens juste que parfois cela suffit
de savoir que c'est difficile."
Et bien sûr parler de chèvre me fait penser automatiquement aux moutons
et pas de manière positive.
(Rire)
Alors, je suis né deux jours après Noël.
Pendant mon enfance, j'avais un gâteau et tout le tralala vous savez,
mais je n'avais jamais de cadeau, étant né deux jours après Noël.
J'avais à peu près neuf ans et mon oncle venait de rentrer d'Allemagne,
le prêtre catholique était à la maison,
ma mère l'avait invité à prendre le thé,
et soudainement mon oncle demanda "Où sont les cadeaux de Chris ?"
Ma mère répondit "Ne parle pas de cela en face les invités."
Mais il avait besoin de montrer qu'il venait juste de revenir,
alors il m'envoya là-haut et me dit:
"Va dans la chambre, dans ma chambre.
Prends ce que tu veux dans ma valise.
C'est ton cadeau d'anniversaire."
Je suis sûr qu'il pensait que j'allais prendre un livre ou une chemise,
mais j'ai trouvé un mouton gonflable.
(Rire)
Alors je l'ai gonflé et je suis descendu au salon,
mon doigt était où il n'aurait pas dû être.
Je paradais avec ce mouton
et ma mère avait l'air de mourir de honte.
(Rire)
Père McGetrick est resté impassible,
il a juste aspiré bruyamment son thé, regardé ma mère et lui a dit :
"Tout va bien Daphné, je suis écossais."
(Rire)
(Applaudissements)
Mes derniers jours passés en prison, les derniers 18 mois,
mon compagnon de cellule ... pour la dernière année, la première année des derniers 18 mois...
Mon compagnon de cellule avait quatorze ans.
Il s'appelait John James,
et à cette époque, si un membre de la famille commettait un crime,
les militaires vous retenait comme rançon
jusqu'à ce que la famille remette le coupable des faits.
Alors, il y avait cet enfant de quatorze ans dans le couloir de la mort.
Et toutes les personnes dans le couloir de la mort n'étaient pas des prisonniers politiques...
il y avait aussi des gens vraiment mauvais ici.
Il avait réussi à faire passer deux bandes dessinées, deux bandes dessinées...
Spiderman et X-men.
Il était un passionné.
Et quand il eu marre de les lire,
il commença à apprendre aux hommes du couloir de la mort à lire
par le biais de ces bandes dessinées.
Et alors, je me souviens nuit après nuit,
on entendait tous ces hommes, ces criminels dangereux,
pressés autour de John James récitant : "Prends ça, Spidey !"
(Rire)
C'est incroyable.
J'étais vraiment inquiet.
Il ne savait pas ce que couloir de la mort signifiait.
J'ai été là-bas deux fois,
et j'étais terrifié à l'idée d'y mourir.
Et il riait et me disait :
"Voyons, nous allons nous en sortir."
Ce à quoi je répondais : "Comment le sais-tu ?"
Il me disait "Oh, je l'ai entendu dire."
Ils l'ont tué.
Ils l'ont menotté à une chaise,
et ils ont fixé son pénis sur une table avec un clou de quinze centimètre.
Puis ils l'ont laissé ici se vider de son sang.
Voilà comment je me suis retrouvé en isolement, car j'avais exprimé ma pensée.
Autour de nous, partout, il y a des gens comme cela.
Les Igbo disaient qu'ils érigeaient leurs propres dieux.
La communauté entière se regroupait,
et ils exprimaient un souhait.
Leur souhait était rapporté au prêtre
qui trouvait alors un objet rituel,
les sacrifices appropriés étaient alors réalisés,
et un sanctuaire était construit pour le dieu.
Mais si le dieu devenait indiscipliné et commençait à réclamer des sacrifices humains,
les Igbos détruisaient le dieu.
Ils détruisaient le sanctuaire,
et arrêtaient d'utiliser le nom du dieu.
C'est ainsi qu'ils en sont venus à récupérer leur humanité.
Tous les jours, nous tous,
nous érigeons des dieux envahissants
et il est temps de les détruire
et d'oublier leurs noms.
Ce n'est pas bien compliqué.
Tout ce que cela demande est de reconnaître parmi nous, tous les jours,
ceux d'entre nous qui peuvent voir, nous sommes entourés de personnes
comme celles dont je vous ai parlé.
Certaines personnes dans cette pièce, des gens merveilleux,
nous tendent un miroir pour y voir notre humanité .
Je voudrais terminer avec un poème d'une poétesse américaine appelé Lucille Clifton.
Ce poème s'appelle "Libation" et il est destiné à mon ami Vusi
qui est dans le public quelque part.
"Libation",
Caroline du Nord, 1999
"J'offre à ce sol ce gin.
J'imagine un vieil homme pleurer ici,
hors de la vue du contremaître.
Il pousse sa langue à travers un trou
où sa dent devrait se trouver, s'il était entier.
Il souffre dans cet espace où sa dent devrait se trouver,
où sa terre devrait se trouver,
sa maison, sa femme, son fils, sa magnifique fille.
Il efface le chagrin de son visage,
met son doigt assoiffé sur sa langue assoiffée,
et goûte le sel.
J'appelle un nom qui pourrait être le sien,
cela est pour vous, vieil homme.
Ce gin, cette terre salée."
Merci.
(Applaudissements)